if you go outside and walk along the  seafront  it won't be long be talk before you get  to a petrol station that's got no fuel  level up  you can't even fill up  and  and conference doesn't that just tell  you everything you need to know about  this government  ignoring the problem  blaming someone else  then coming up with a half-baked  solution  why do we suddenly have a shortage of  hgv drivers  why is there no plan in place  a tank of fuel already cost 10 pounds  more than it did at the start of the  year  gas and electricity bills up  gaps in the supermarket shelves  rent up especially for those on the  lowest incomes  yet this  is the very moment  the government is putting up tax on  working people  putting up tax on small business  and shamefully slashing  universal credit the lifeline for six  million families  [Applause]  we have a fuel crisis  a pay crisis a goods crisis and a cost  of living crisis all at the same time  you